Hello and welcome to Emax30 highlights at Emax2024. Before I begin, I'd like to thank
the organizers and everyone involved for pushing this all together. While the talk is being
prerecorded, my experience from the last few years ensures me that it will be a great
experience for everyone. My name is Philip Callagyarchich, I am a
core contributor and Al Paco maintainer. I was honored when Sasha asked me to take over
the slot for this year. In the past few iterations, Jon Weekly has filled a similar presentation
focusing on more general Emax development updates. This year, I will specifically focus
on highlight features from the upcoming Emax30 release, which might or might not have been
released by the time you are seeing this. As you can imagine, everything you're about
Emax can always be found in the Emax News file. Alternatively, if one doesn't want to read
through the multiple thousand lines here, one can also take a look at the Emax FAQ and
then go to what's different about Emax30. Next to these two official options, I also have
a page on Emax Wicking called Emax30 highlights some of the interesting features with some
context and suggestions on how to try them out. This is more of a collaborative effort,
so if you see this and think something is missing, feel free to add it. So without further
ado, let's begin taking a look at new features in Emax30. The biggest one in the one I
once mentioned first is Android support, native Android support. As you can see here,
Emax has been ported to the Android operating system. What this means is that from Emax30 onwards,
you can build Android to target Android devices natively and using a graphical interface.
While this has been possible to run Emax inside of Terminal Emulators in Android for a while,
this actually means that you can use Emax on an Android device or phone or tablet and have
all the usual advantages from Gweemax, such as the ability to vines or commands without
having to worry about all keys without having to worry about Terminal compatibility issues,
displaying images and multiple fonts on the same display of different sizes. I should have
a recording of that somewhere here, which I made earlier on my phone because I'm recording
this on the laptop, where we can see how touch interaction works on an Android phone so
I can switch between buffers and here I've connected an external keyboard, opening the
Emax website and we have images that we can interact with or we could resize them if we
wanted to, with the image resizing commands, pitch to zoom works, so it does realize what
touch screen interactions are with an external mouse and, for example, enabling context menu
mode. I can even pop up little interaction windows, which one would usually also know from
Gweemax, but Tweemax also supports them since a while now. In this case, I'm demonstrating
how even the touch screen events can be inspected using the usual hot-help system and how
context mode notices where we are and allows me to, for example, evaluate this specific
region, which I've highlighted down there, finding a command to touch screen scroll. One should
note that these additions, for example, touch screen interaction are not specific to Android,
but they also are supported in other operating systems such as, well, Walens and Exog, which
are not operating systems, and Windows. Insofar, they have touch screen and devices, have
touch screen support. One should mention, or I want to mention that the main developer behind
this feature, Paulu, should be complemented for the additional effort he put into making
sure that Emax and Android, Emax for Android, can be built using only a free software toolchain,
which is certainly not something one has come to expect from working on Android applications,
as usually you have to agree to some terms and conditions for Google's specific software.
Final notice is that if you try and look for this online, there is an APK, which there
are APKs you can find, but some of them might be outdated. The best of my knowledge, Paulu
has Emax 30 Android Source Vorge, set up some system here in Source Vorge. There are regular
and go away. There are regular and updated APK files which you can download to avoid having
to build it yourself, but testing out the newest version in case there are some bugs which
you'd like to report. Next up, Vorge Key, is a package which has now been moved from
Albert to the core. If you haven't heard of Vorge Key before, the idea is, or the general
pitches at Vorge Key is a additional documentation interface for Emax for displaying various keys
which you could input or various keys and keymaps that have been partially inputted. The better
way to demonstrate this or to explain this is just a show it. If we enable the which key
mode, it's a global minor mode, then I can press, for example, Control X, which is a prefix
for the Control X. Keymap and then down here in the buffer, in this window down here we
see various commands which we could invoke and the keys to invoke them with. For example,
if I wanted to say, Control X, I for insert file, then I just have to press I, which was,
I mean, so highlight this once again. It should be down here, yes. Pressing I without having
to repeat the entire key code again, but partial key code again just works. This is different
from the feature which Emax has already, which is just to, if you have input to the partial
key code, you can press Control H and then a help buffer pops up with a listing of all
key bindings that start with Control X. The information is the same, the presentation is
different because now if I wanted to do Control X, I have to repeat the entire key code again.
So it's a matter of personal preference, which you prefer. This is more of a traditional
static approach, because of course I get a help buffer where I can, which I can search
and use in usual key commands, which key is more of a transient and modern, some might
say, some might prefer that approach to solving the same problem. Also, don't forget to check
out the customization group for which key, which has a number of options which you might
or might not be trusted in. Next up, Emax30 has built-in editor conflict support. If you
have not heard of editor conflict before, believe I've linked to it down here somewhere,
there it is, editor conflict. This is a file format used to specify common, common formatting
rules in an editor-agnostic way. You might compare it to der local files, which is a sort
of an S expression for setting file local variables in Emax, but of course this is restricted
to the common subset of what all editors should understand, for example, indentation styles,
whether they prefer tabs or spaces and tab with filing, coding and so on. So it's nothing
to advance, but it is a file format, which one sees, popping up more and more often in
a lot of projects which want to enforce a consistent indentation style or formatting rules for
all editors in a project. Having this built-in is certainly useful in Emax, though we should
note that it's not enabled by default, so you still have to enable the global minimum,
which is simply turning on this one option. It shouldn't be more than that, and then Emax
will respect the rules. If it finds an editor-conflict file in the project directory, then it will
respect those rules without having to do anything else.
Next up, use package integration with Package Vc. So for those of you familiar with the two
words, names, next up, use package integration with Package Vc. For those of you familiar with
either of the two or at least one of the two, use package is a popular configuration marker.
What it does is it allows users to declaratively specify packages they'd like to have installed
and configured in their configuration file. So that, for example, if you copy your init.cl
from one system to another, it could bootstrap the entire configuration, downloading all
the packages you want, without having to manually do this on every system you'd like to use,
which allows configurations to be self encapsulated and portable. Package Vc is an extension of Package
EL, which allows installing packages from an alternative or instead of using the standard
way to install packages, which is just down the target and on the package, like compilers
and so on, it will fetch the files for a package directly from the source code repository
and initialize it in such a way that Package EL can work with it. So it's just a front-end
for installing packages. Even though these two are added the next 29, we didn't have the
time to work on the use package integration of Package Vc into use package, which has been
changed now. So what we have with Emex29 is that we can, there is a Vc keyword for use package
with which we can instruct use package to not download a package using table, but instead
to fetch the source code from a source code repository. This is useful if you, for example,
have packages which you yourself work on and know that you always want to have the development
version of the package where you can directly commit changes you've made to the repository
and push them upstream, or if you know that you want to contribute to a package, you can
use Package Vc to download the source code, have all the version of the total information,
prepare a patch and send it upstream. In these examples here, we have, once the
first example lists, instructs Package Vc to download the source code from a URL. So this
is a GIT URL where it will download the source code from, and in this case, choose the
new list checkout of the source code, not the latest release. And down here we have another
example, or I prefer to consider the following example here, if we just had wrote written
this, then Package Vc would use the metadata which an helper server provides to fetch the
URL from the official repository of, in this case, BBDP without having to, so it would
be more or less the same like this up here, with a simple or with a single difference
that Package Vc integration into use package doesn't check out the latest, the latest commit
but the latest release, just to keep configurations more deterministic by default. Of course, if
you prefer to use latest commit, you can use the Package Vc install command, or just update
the Package manually yourself, which you can use using Package Vc upgrade. Next, I'd like
to focus on a few features which one might next necessarily realize directly, but will
hopefully improve your experience with Emacs. First up, in this list is a new JSON parser,
let's maybe show the source code for that one, and I'll now JSON.dr, JSON, yeah, JSON.c.
For those, the history of JSON parsing Emacs started with Emacs 23 with the addition of JSON.dr,
this was a file which we have just opened a moment ago. This is a JSON parser in Emacs.lisp,
it's fine, it does the job, but it can get slow if we have a situation like where Eglot
uses a sp server to communicate with it, and the sp server can get a bit chatty, sending
a lot of JSON data, which all has to be parsed and garbage collected, which can slow down
Emacs a bit. The situation was improved upon in Emacs 29 with the addition or when JSON
parsing was added to the core, this was the JSON.c file, which we see on this side of the
old version of JSON.c file, which employed the Janssen library, it's the C library for parsing
and accelerating JSON parsing in Emacs. This was good enough, or it certainly improved
the situation for lots of LSP clients, but in Emacs 30, the situation has been improved
one small by implementing or with the addition of a JSON parser directly in Emacs. So instead
of using an external library, there's a custom JSON parser written in C in the Emacs core,
which directly generates Eglot objects. The advantage to this approach, compared to the
Janssen approach, is that there's no intermediate form at which has to be allocated and memory
managed and freeed again, which of course incurs an additional performance overhead.
Next to this is also a custom serializing for JSON contents, so translating a JSON object
into a string, meaning that the consequence of this is that there is absolutely no dependency
on Janssen anymore. This in turn means that now all Emacs users from Emacs 30 onwards
can take advantage of this new JSON parser and don't have to worry about whether or not
they have Janssen, this JSON parsing library installed on this system or not, when they want
to take advantage of this accelerated JSON parsing. Next up, another behind the scenes feature
is that if you build Emacs on your own from source, you might know that if you want
to use native compilation, so the translation of elus bytecode to whatever the native assembly
or native instruction set is on your system, you had to specify with native compilation
when voting the configure script, otherwise it would not have been enabled at all. With Emacs
30, this step is not necessary anymore. In case the configure script will automatically
check if you have the lib gcc jits library installed on your system and if that is so, then
native compilation will be enabled by default. In other words, if you have an issue with
native compilation or prefer not to use it for whatever reason, you never have to type
without native compilation when compiling Emacs to prevent this from happening. But native
compilation was added in Emacs 28 and has proven to be a very stable and useful feature
for most people. So there's probably no reason to do this and you can just invoke the configure
script with one argument less. Right, and I'd like to finish up with a few smaller features,
a few smaller highlights. Maybe we can go back to this thing here. First up is, whoops,
here we have it, there are a few new major modes based on the Tristeter library. Tristeter
is this parser library, which has been integrated into Emacs 29 that allows or it allows the integration
of external specialized and quick parses into Emacs, which improves stuff like syntax highlighting,
indentation, structural navigation. I many supports by simply having a better understanding
of an elisp file or not an elisp file of, for example, a HTML file or a Lua file, a PHP file,
and what people usually implement using regular expressions in traditional major modes. So a
few new major modes, which you can try out here. Another interesting feature is the completion
preview mode. You can maybe try it out here in this scratch buffer. If I enable complete
sound preview mode, this is a local and non-global minor mode, which will display completion options
in inline using overlays. For example, if I start typing along the symbol like define, yeah,
now we had a derived mode, it suggests me to, I can just press tab and then it completes the
option here, but it didn't actually, it's not actually modifying the buffer, it's not pressing, these
are just overlays. So if I move around, it gets deleted, it wouldn't get saved if I was saved the buffer.
The same also should work in a shell buffer, so if I enable completion preview mode here and starts,
in this case, I'm using the bash completion package, which provides additional completion
information, so this is not only limited to programming systems, but anywhere where you have
completion at point. If I can start typing here, ignore, but ignore backups, and it's
hints to the options which I have and allows me to complete them quickly.
Another small feature is the package isolate command. What this does is it will start, or it will
prompt me for a few, for packages I have installed in my system, and will start an isolated, or
like EMEX-Q-ish instance of EMEX, with only these packages installed. So for example, if I set
I1-slime, and I1-dif-hl, then this is a new EMEX window, it's unrelated to the one around, it
uses the same executable, of course, but will not load your configuration file,
or any other further customizations on your system. All it does, it will ensure that these packages,
which are listed here. So in RK-slime, and dependencies of Slime, and Dif-hl,
in the system, so that I could, for example, as you can see here, Dif-hl mode worked by,
okay, this is not a version controlled file, maybe if we take a look at
by enabled Dif-hl mode, it's enabled, in this case, what Dif-hl mode does is it displays these
version controlled changes in the fringe of a buffer, and even though this is a
un-customized version of EMEX, or un-customized instance of EMEX, it was easy for me to load this one
package, or these two packages, and all the dependencies necessary. As you can imagine, the main
purpose for this is to make debugging issues easier, if you want to report an issue, you have
all the package, and if I close this, it's closed, and everything is thrown away.
Last up a nice feature, I think a lot of people will appreciate is if you are familiar with,
let's open a text buffer, the Metacube key, Metacube is traditionally bound to fill a paragraph,
what this means is now, so let's, for example, copy this text from here, and
squash it all into one line, if I press Metacube here, then the lines will be broken
according to the fill column indicator up here. This is a traditional usage of Metacube,
and it still works in text mode buffers, but in prog mode buffers, so any major mode inheriting
prog mode, Metacube will now by default be bound to prog fill re-indense defun. What is basically
or to summarize the points, if you are editing a string, then or a comment, then the comment will
be filled, but if you are outside of a comment or outside of a string, then the defun or the top level
construct in the programming language will be re-indented. Let's try that out with maybe some file I have
open here, if I'm in this, let's choose some function, let's take this example. If we follow
the order of this again, and I press Metacube in on this paragraph, then the paragraph gets re-indented,
but if I'm down here, and I choose to break the indentation and then press Metacube,
then as you see, only then it's practically selected the defun and re-indented everything without
having to move the points around in the buffer. So I think that's a really nice feature,
which a lot of people can appreciate, it's one of those niceties, which come from time to time.
So that was my overview of what's going to be new in Emacs 30. I hope that most people could take
away something from this presentation and have something to look forward to, to try out after
upgrading. As mentioned initially, as of recording, this release has not been completed yet,
and if this is still not the case as soon as when you're seeing this video, please consider
downloading and building Emacs 30 yourself. And if you have any issues, which is always the case,
please report them to using Emacs, what's going to report Emacs, but that will pop up a mail buffer,
and then you can describe your shouldn't send them out. All bug reports are valuable,
even if they are false positives or duplicates, it doesn't matter, because when you take the time to
submit a bug report, which describes something that's specific to your setup, what should the
developers might not have noticed or known about, and you are certainly helping out a lot of other
people, which might run into the same issue in the future. And especially with upgrades,
it would be nice to figure out small problems, which make upgrading difficult for some people.
The idea is, of course, the idea is, of course, to have no issues when upgrading from one
verge to another. Having said that, I thank you for your attention and I'm saying goodbye.